بمجرد أن يضع شخص ما فنجان القهوة
أو صندوق الكرتون المستخدم في إعادة التدوير ،
فإنه لا يفكر أبدًا في التعقيد
والبنية التحتية اللازمة
لإزالة تلك المواد
، تواجه الولايات المتحدة مشكلة إعادة التدوير
منذ أن توقفت الصين عن شراء
ملايين الأطنان من إعادة التدوير الأمريكية
في عام 2018.
كافح من أجل التوصل إلى
حل طويل الأمد
، وتقول epa إن أحد أكبر
التحديات هو التلوث
الذي يمكن أن تتعطل فيه عملية إعادة التدوير إذا
اختلطت القمامة بمواد قابلة لإعادة التدوير
إذا كانت المادة ملوثة
ولم نتمكن من إعادة استخدامها
نحن  يجب أن ترسل هذه المواد
إلى مدافن النفايات للمساعدة في مكافحة المشكلة ،
يقوم علم التخييم بتثبيت الكاميرات في
حاويات القمامة الخاصة بعملائه ويستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي لاكتشاف التلوث في
الوقت الفعلي
إذا حصل العميل على تنبيه لإزالته
كيف يمكنك تدريب نظام ذكاء اصطناعي ليكون
منطقيًا
من كومة القمامة الحرفية ،
نستخدم تقنيات التعلم الآلي الأكثر تقدمًا والتي
تسمى الشبكات العصبية ، حيث
نلتقط صورًا بثلاثة أضعاف  o خمس مرات في
اليوم
نتتبع امتلاء نوع المواد التي تدخل
داخلها وعندما يتم صيانة هذه الحاوية ،
كلما زادت دقة الصور التي نحصل عليها
من داخل حاويات القمامة ، كلما كان من
الممكن أن نكون أكثر دقة
لعملاء الشركة ، بما في ذلك nordstrom
capital one
starbucks adt و mcdonald's
يتلقى مديرو المطاعم لدينا
إخطارًا في
أي وقت يكون لدينا فيه حالة
انتهاك ، لذا تساعد هذه التقنية حقًا
في
تثقيف موظفينا بطريقة سريعة جدًا
، كما تكتشف الكاميرات أيضًا مقدار
النفايات التي يتم التخلص منها في سلة المهملات أو صندوق إعادة التدوير
مما يساعد على ضمان
تفريغ الشاحنات القلابة لهم فقط  عندما يكون ممتلئًا
والذي بدوره
يوفر على العملاء أموالًا عند التقاطهم ،
فقد شهد أحمر الخدود الأولي لدينا انخفاضًا بنسبة 31
في نفاياتنا التي تنفق عددًا أقل من
الشاحنات الصغيرة مما يعني أيضًا أن الشاحنات القلابة تقضي وقتًا أقل في
القيادة مما يؤدي إلى انخفاض
انبعاثات الكربون عبر وادي لاس فيجاس ،
وقد تمكنا من ذلك  تقليل بصمتنا الكربونية
بأكثر من 8000 ميل من الشاحنات المقطوعة في
هذه العملية ، مما يقلل انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون بمقدار
32 طنًا متريًا.  تمتلك 162
كاميرا تلتقط صورًا في حاويات القمامة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
لكنها لا تزال تمثل تأثيرًا طفيفًا في
مشاكل صناعة إعادة التدوير ،
يتفق الخبراء على أن تعليم المستهلك بشكل أفضل
أمر بالغ الأهمية ،
ومن المهم حقًا أن تكون قادرًا على
فهم ما يحدث
داخل حاوية القمامة الخاصة بك من أجل
تحسين سلوكياتك حول
إعادة التدوير  وتقليل كمية
النفايات التي تذهب إلى مكبات النفايات